Johnson & Johnson was ordered to pay
more than a half a billion dollars after
the first ever trial addressing who's to
blame for the opioid crisis and Oklahoma
judge ruled yesterday that misleading
marketing led to addictions and deadly
overdoses of opioids the consumer
products giant plans to appeal the 572
million dollar verdict
Omar Villafranca is at the courthouse in
Norman Oklahoma
Omar how's the company reacting well
good morning the company is calling the
judge's ruling flawed but the state of
Oklahoma and their attorneys say they're
prepared to defend this case all the way
to the Supreme Court if necessary now
there are thousands of other similar
cases set to go to trial and attorneys
in those cases are calling this decision
a milestone the opioid crisis has
ravaged the state of Oklahoma it must be
a made it evaded immediately with those
words District Judge Thad Balkman
ordered Johnson & Johnson and its
subsidiary Janssen pharmaceuticals to
pay five hundred seventy two million
dollars in damages ruling the company's
opioid marketing was false deceptive and
misleading exponentially increasing
rates of addiction and overdose deaths
which totaled more than 4,600 according
to Attorney General Mike hunter Johnson
& Johnson motivated by greed and avarice
is responsible for the opioid epidemic
in our state the judge agreed that
Johnson and Johnson created a public
nuisance unlawfully doing an act which
injures or endanger the health or safety
of others I feel like my boy was looking
down State Attorney Reggie Whitten says
he lost his son to opioid addiction my
son was a good boy that got sick and we
know what
I know what caused it now we have
sympathy for all who suffer from
substance abuse Johnson & Johnson
attorney Sabrina strong says the verdict
presents serious constitutional problems
I think the nation's opioid abuse crisis
is a serious public health issue you
nobody disputes that but you can't sue
your way out of the opioid abuse crisis
some 2,000 similar lawsuits have been
consolidated involving state and local
governments they begin to go to trial
before a federal judge in Ohio this fall
in a statement lawyers for those cases
say the Oklahoma judgment is a milestone
amid the mounting evidence against the
opioid pharmaceutical industry these
companies knew what was going on at the
highest level they just couldn't quit
making money from it and that's why
they're responsible Johnson & Johnson
says the state disregarded 100 years of
legal precedent when they were arguing
the public nuisance in this case and
they also added that the decision here
in Oklahoma will not affect the federal
cases going forward Tony
Omar two other companies were originally
named in this suit what happened to them
mm-hmm both decided to actually settle
before the trial you had Purdue Pharma
they settled for two hundred and seventy
million dollars Tempah pharmaceuticals
485 million neither admitted any
wrongdoing Johnson & Johnson is having
to pay five hundred and seventy two
million basically double what Purdue had
to pay and they're gonna have this
stigma of having having a judge ruling
against the company they do say they
will appeal though Oumar thank you very
much